pour une fois elle évite alors jugée
loin un avion prix forfaitaire pour deux
mois les retours avec lui conseille au
fromage ou dessert quart de vin compris
c'est très avantagé mais j'étais venu
parce que c'est le jour émouvant du
départ et c'est mon premier reportage
qui voyagent au une amie qui viennent
dire au revoir
sophie desmarais quel amour ma chérie on
m'a assez soir on s'est trop gentil
d'être venu tous voulaient profiter des
photographes photographes ne me fait pas
rire j'ai vu ton bon frère n'ont
peut-être pas partir seul si loin à
tonnage alors j'ai demandé à maman te
prêter son châle on sait jamais assez
les courants d'air avec un arthro c'est
gentil mais tu n'aurais pas dû courir
comme ça ça donne un visage tout ravages
inquiète pas pour ta copine elle a du
ressort
j'ai aussi pris les boules de gomme
qu'on a lorsque j'en ai mangé suisse
atteint vers les antilles il aura en
outre un ton choix toi parce qu'en ce
moment je trouve un peu à peu près sera
bon signe
madame je vous en prie descendez le sou
du décollage qui doutaient qu'ils n'ont
pas l'habitude d'être plaqué chéri puis
je pars tu restes tu m'as compris je te
confie pas assez jolie ce que tu viens
de dire c'est très joli que je sors
mi-chemin par ici surtout plus énervante
selon tsn très émouvant au bon dieu
au revoir et vive la france au revoir ma
chérie dès lors bien je joue tous les
soirs à 8h30 chauffer mercredi ont
renchéri bon voyage je leur dirai tout
ce que je pense de toi aimer courir
mais pourquoi ils ont déjà enlevé la
passerelle